hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Q&A about future of Science
and
Technology let me see number of
questions saved up here there's one from
Aaron what will prompt engineering be
like if llms are super
intelligent you know I have to say it's
an interesting question you know what
are Minds like if they're different from
ours like if they are super intelligent
relative to us I've been kind of
wondering about this I've been wondering
about it for a long time but I've been
thinking about a bit recently
um here's a here's a question so you
know we humans have what 86 billion
neurons in our brains you know ants have
50,000 it's clear we humans manage to do
more than ants manage to do question is
if we scaled up and somehow you know I
don't know through genetic modification
or through neural implants or whatever
else we effectively had oh I don't know
uh a trillion neurons in our
brains what would the consequences of
that be and how would would that make us
you know you kind of always in the
science fiction movies of the the super
intelligent aliens I think these have
gone kind of gone out of fashion these
days but used to be the case the super
intelligent aliens would have bigger
heads and you know maybe there's
something to that now one thing that is
a a feature of of our sort of human uh
Consciousness is that we we tend to
believe that we have sort of a single
thread of experience and it may be
non-trivial to achieve kind of a single
thread of experience even with 86
billion neurons and for example we have
some evidence that when we generate
language there are certain parts of the
brain brain that are critical to being
able to you know Yak on with human
language and if you if those parts of
the brain stop working you know broker's
area whatever else stop working then you
are no longer able to Yak on and produce
language but it seems like much more of
the brain is somehow involved in the
production of things you're saying
that's just some kind of gate that
things have to pass through to to
actually get out into the um into the
expressed kind of linguistic world and
so you know so potentially much of our
brain is being sort of corraled into
having this thread of experience and all
these different neurons are somehow
cooperating to give us this one thread
of experience I don't think it's really
very clear how that works I mean we know
that certain nerves in brains if they
don't work one doesn't form the single
threat of experience one knows that in
in various kinds of psychiatric
conditions you know one ends up with
multiple personalities and things like
this and there are sort of somehow that
that's happening sort of within the same
brain so to speak it's rather unclear
how all of that works but so you know
one thing that's important for us humans
at least is that we have this sort of
single thread of experience whether you
know the the I don't know you know
shocks where you know they have two
sides of the brain and one's Asleep At A
Time type thing whether they
um uh have um uh whether they also have
a single threat of experience like we do
I I don't know I I would guess yes but I
don't know it's kind of like you know
this this time of day it's my left brain
working this time of day it's my right
brain working you know we've got
different personalities who knows it's
unclear I don't think we we know you
know because we can't really see or
imagine those brains from the inside but
so the question arises okay let's say we
had a trillion neurons instead of 100
billion neurons what will be different
so a few guesses so one thing is it's a
it's a common feature of human language
that we have roughly
50,000 words that we commonly use 30 to
50,000 words that we commonly use in
whatever language we speak and that
seems to be sort of the number of
Concepts we can hold in our brain
somehow roughly now maybe the cats and
dogs with smaller brains or something uh
and and by the way when we talk about
brain size there's also issues about the
size of the organism like you know
whales have big brains but they're very
big organisms I suspect that a lot of
that brain I don't know but I suspect a
lot of it is used up in kind of sensory
uh just there are a lot of nerve endings
that come from you know the piece of the
tail of the whale it's just a big
surface area and if you don't cover that
with nerve endings then you know when
something happens to a little piece of
the tail of the whale then the whale
doesn't notice unless it's got nerve
endings coming from there and uh the you
know the the the structure of these
things is roughly that the nerves just
end up in the brain I mean they may go
through some ganglion that consolidates
them a bit but fundamentally to know
sort of the map of where things are
happening on you is just directly sent
as you know different fibers to the
brain so so maybe you know when you have
a bigger animal it's got a bigger brain
partly just because it's sensing more
surface area but so the the the S higher
brain functions may not be any bigger I
don't know um
but so uh you know one of the things
that is sort of a general feature of how
we seem to operate is that we are making
this kind of objectified symbolic
version of the world things happen we
see all this detail but we describe it
in terms of The Limited number of words
that we have so we are we're kind of
equivalencing all of these this is I was
writing about this recently in
connection with what I've been calling
Observer Theory we're kind of
equivalencing down all these different
details about what the world is like
and describing it just in terms of for
example these pieces of language that
are what we care about like I see a
camera in front of me I could get into
great detail about how it's got this
particular circular thing and the square
thing and this and that and the other
and it's a this type of camera and that
type of camera I can't even read what
yes I can read what it says here um but
I'm not getting into any of those
details for many purposes of my thinking
about things all I need to know is the
word camera it's a camera that's my kind
of overall description of it so a
question would be you know a hypothesis
would be the bigger the brain the more
different kinds of uh sort of Concepts
you can deal with roughly measured in
terms of the number of words you can
deal with and I think that's an
interesting I mean so you know assume
you scale up the brain by a factor of 10
maybe you get 10 times as many words
what does that mean I mean for example
we can ask for an AI for an llm for
example uh as we scale up the size of
the
llm the uh uh it's some um how does that
affect the number of sort of internal
Concepts that it forms now unfortunately
we don't really understand the formation
of internal Concepts in an LM I mean we
can understand something about how it
represents things in the world in terms
of vectors of numbers and so on but the
idea that we have as humans that we kind
of describe the world in terms of these
symbolic things like cameras and tables
and chairs is something where the
formation of those kinds of Concepts is
not you know I don't know how to think
about that in connection with things
like llms um I think it would be
interesting to understand that a bit I
think that one can sort of say at a
qualitative level if one has something
like an image identifier and you're
looking at this convolutional neural net
it's got many layers and you can kind of
say that that at some layer you can kind
of see this in terms of sort of the
activation densities and so on at some
layer it's noticing this feature of the
image or that feature of the image often
those are features for which we don't
have specific words um and we could
imagine that sort of with bigger brains
we could have those words as well so a
question would be sort of what can you
do with with a bigger vocabulary I mean
we kind of have the impression that um
you know it's always impressive when
people when humans
have a bigger vocabulary I don't know
whether that's cause or effect and I
don't know whether I I mean I kind of
think that the the bigger vocabulary the
more Concepts you can think in terms of
and that's presumably a useful thing but
can we characterize what it means to
think in terms of more kinds of Concepts
and can that what does that tell us
about kind of how we what it means to be
sort of super intelligent and uh uh you
know what that sort of feels like to us
you know we have our limited for example
we we're interacting with the super
intelligent AI whatever um you know we
just have our limited set of Concepts
and maybe it has these other ones which
it can perhaps use as intermediate
stages in things that's working out
which it then Dums down to the concepts
that we know and perhaps there's a
there's a way in which that works I mean
it's sort of an interesting thing we
already see this in in areas like
mathematics where you know you can get
an answer that involves one set of
Concepts but the path to getting that
answer can sometimes involve going sort
of uphill to some fancier concept so we
see this if we're doing automated
theorem proving for example and we say
what's the size of the intermediate
theorems we have to prove to get to the
theorem we want the theorem we want
might be quite small but there might be
these really big intermediate theorems
that we have to prove to get there or
another example from sort of mathematics
famous example from what 1500 or
something is in solving the cubic
equation you even if you are going to
get in the end a real number out the
intermediate parts of the expression may
involve complex numbers which cancel
their imaginary parts so in the end it's
real but we don't know somehow we have
to go uphill to this fancier concept
space with introducing Concepts like
complex numbers even though we're going
to come back down to the simplest
situation later so I don't think you
know so I mean that's one sort of model
of the sort of the super intelligent is
yes it can handle those more complicated
intermediate stages even though in the
end it's going to make things simple for
us and we're going to look at it and
we're going to say we can't get from
place a to place B in that Chain of
Thought because we in order to do that
we'd have to go to this more complicated
concept that we don't readily fit in our
brains and if if in a sense sort of the
idea of universal computation and so on
suggests that you can in principle
construct any concept from its kind of
primitive pieces but what in a sense is
happening when we invent a word we know
a word we're sort of caching that
concept we're kind of saying we know
what that is it's a camera you know so
blah blah blah we don't have to say it's
a thing that takes light and turns it
into electronic image you know
electronic data in an array blah blah
blah we can just say it's a camera so
it's sort of a caching of a certain
amount of
information so again I I don't really
know how to think about what else you
can say about the world sort of if you
turn that knob of sort of what uh you
know what does it mean if you have a
bigger vocabulary I don't really know
what that what that lets one do uh it's
an interesting question I mean one can
answer that to some extent for this in
this case of uh just saying let's make a
bigger bag of intermediate theorems for
theorem proving actually it's a
something I should be able to answer
from the stuff I've done the book I
wrote about metam mathematics for
example probably has implicitly some of
the answers to those kinds of questions
of to what extent can you sort of uh how
how much do you how much gain do you get
from having a bigger cache of
intermediate theorems maybe I've even
looked at that um Yes actually I have
looked at that uh but I don't know a
good sort of qualitative answer to that
question so I mean that's one type of
thing another kind of thing is sensory
input I mean we have you know 10 million
nerve fibers coming from our eyes we
have 50,000 from
Myas um you know certain number of nerve
fibers imagine that we were more
intelligent so to speak and we could
connect to much broader sensory input so
imagine oh I don't
know imagine we had sort of uh uh well
even even imagine we were sort of a
community that had sort of telepathic
communication with lots of other
organisms which were walking around and
had eyes and so on and we could get all
that data in now in a sense in in modern
times and through Digital Electronics we
can get all of that data in you know we
can be watching the webcam you know the
the million webcams or something we can
be taking in all this Internet of Things
data and so on
one of the things that's true is we
don't know what the heck to do with all
of that data because we in most of our
world is used to the experience we have
of of you know vision and and hearing
and so on the limited data that we get
into our sensory systems by the time
you're sort of accumulating tons more
data about the world it's not something
that we are intrinsically built to deal
with you know we can try and use science
to break it down and turn that data into
some kind of human narrative but we
weren't built to deal with that maybe if
we had a trillion neurons in our brains
we'd be and we had more sensory inputs
we'd be more in a position to do that
maybe we have the direct I'm somehow
thinking of the Matrix movie or
something you know we had the direct
neural connection to electronics so to
speak um and we could sort of just plug
into all these sensors out there in the
world what would we make of all of that
you know it's it's funny because one
thing we clearly know there is structure
in all data I mean this is the story of
quantitative Finance for example tends
to be if you get enough data about the
world and you look for regularities you
will find some maybe it's getting more
difficult to find them but it's still
the case that there are with enough data
there are regularities to be found which
a an ordinary human brain has a very
hard time finding but if you're kind of
bringing all all that stuff if you could
bring it in if you had a much bigger
brain and you could bring it into that
you would start to notice those
regularities as a kind of as an everyday
thing and I suppose an interesting
question is if you're a human or an AI
for that matter who's growing up in an
environment of I don't know equities
markets or something and you you're
routinely getting tick by tick data of
all of that stuff when you're routinely
getting all these other things you know
what do you how do you form your
worldview what if you uh and I I start
thinking about sort of what con you form
but that's a tricky business because
language is intrinsically a quite
societal kind of construct in other
words the fact that I'm you know saying
a bunch of words and etc etc etc I
learned those words when I was very
young and I learned them from other
humans and now I'm using those words to
communicate with other humans if I was
just me on my own I I think occasionally
while somebody like me who likes to
think of new ideas I do occasionally
make up words for things where I will
describe something in terms of a word
that nobody else has ever heard and
maybe nobody else will ever hear it I'm
just using that as an internal marker
for myself to represent a concept that
I've come up with but that's a rare case
the more common case of words is that
there kind of this social construct that
allows for communication between between
different people so I'm not even sure
that you know if you have this
completely different sensory experience
do you form unless you have something to
talk to that's had similar sensory
experience not even sure what words you
form so in any case I I suppose a few um
thoughts you know I'll tell you a a
thought that I was was just trying to
form actually was um has to do with the
following question
in uh you look
at these very complicated systems in the
world like I think uh you know I gather
you know cars have 10,000 components
planes have 100,000 components um in you
know in the the things that you sort of
separately describe when you're doing
the design for these systems biological
systems have even more components but
somehow these components have certain
structure to the way that they're
organized and the way that they they
form you know subsystems etc etc etc and
the thing I was was sort of sort of
interesting perhaps is one
characteristic feature seems to be
that subsystems are formed a subsystem
where there's a lot of stuff going on
inside the subsystem but its exposure to
the outside world is thin and that's
very similar to us as observers of the
natural world there's all this stuff
going on in the natural world but we
have this thin pipe that the sort of
thin set of things that we are forming
in our minds to represent that those are
the parts of that that we care about and
I think it's the same type of thing when
you have a big system you have these
subsystem systems whether it's in
biology or in in systems engineering you
have these subsystems that have these
sort of apis these connections to the
outside world that are somehow limited
now somehow those connections are a
little bit like languages they're a
little bit like the fact that you've
aggregated sort of all the detail of
what's Happening inside into a limited
number of kind of symbolic Concepts
which you are then communicating to
other subsystems and so it's sort of a a
story of of how do you uh you know it's
um you're using this kind of thinner
Communication channel between subsystems
and you're using that as a way to
organize the whole system rather than
having everything communicate with
everything and one wonders kind of to
what extent well even sort of biology
has done that at all scales whether On's
dealing with cells whether one's dealing
with organisms that interact with the
whole sort of species and ecosystem and
so on it's it seems to kind of at all
levels have this kind of approach where
where sort of a cell is something which
has a certain nature that has you know
just a membrane that has you know uh
receptors on the surface and so on that
has a limited kind of set of set of ways
in which it communicates with other
other systems and I I think it's sort of
a question of what is I've been thinking
about this kind of uh theory of bulk
orchestration kind of what is it that
describes a
microprocessor or an airplane or a or a
uh uh or a biological system that says
we've got a lot of components here but
they are somehow uh the how can you make
a bulk statement about what's going on
when those components are organized how
are they organized I think what one's
understanding is they're organized in
these subsystems and uh uh that's sort
of what makes them for example
comprehensible to us in any way um but
uh uh you know I I don't know quite
where this is is going because I haven't
sort of figured this out but I think in
terms of this question about sort of the
super intelligence question uh one of
the things that comes to mind is sort of
how big can these subsystems be and how
much how complicated can their sort of
apis their connections to the outside
world be and that sort of characteristic
of kind of something related to kind of
the the the intrinsic processing power
of systems is is how much uh how much
that how big that interface can be how
big the language that describes how this
subsystem interfaces with the outside
world can be just a few thoughts
there let's
see
uh em is commenting maybe language is
stopping us getting some ideas because
we cannot formulate the idea in our
known languages absolutely I mean that's
that's that's the story of much advance
in science and other areas is to form
these Concepts form these descriptions
of things because that's what you use to
sort of build the next level of the
Tower and obviously my theory of that in
my life has been build our computational
language W from language and build
Concepts into that as we progressively
understand them precisely so that you
can get to sort of higher levels in this
Tower I mean i' I've sort of been living
that theory
um let's
see a comment from prab about a comment
from Elon about most of our memory is
digital now and the same will happen
with
Concepts well I mean what one
stores is not the we might choose
nowadays to store the raw bits we just
store the
video whether
we in a sense by storing the video were
already compressing the data a lot those
individual photons that fell on our our
receptor they fell in a particular order
and they had all kinds of details and
they had all kinds of directions and so
on but we're equivalencing all that out
we're just storing the video now we can
imagine that there are aspects of that
just like you know we get transcripts of
uh you know um Zoom like sessions that
we do and uh uh then the question is do
we store the whole transcript every word
every cough or do we store the you know
do we get rid of the coughs do we get
rid of the ums and S do we do we store
just the summary you know this is a
again it it continues to be a story of
of what do we care about what do we
choose to to to store and deal with and
so
on
um uh Eddie is commenting that creatures
like cuttlefish and
octopus um must have something different
going on in their brains
um and uh because they can do things
like mimic the outside world with their
color and texture and so on yeah yeah
it's an interesting question I don't
know I I I um uh was talking to an
expert in um uh cuttlefish Etc
perception recently and um uh it's very
hard to wrap one's brain around a very
different kind of brain
and I you know I think the only
statement is that sometimes things like
octopuses seem smarter than they are
and well Smarter with respect to what we
think of as smart because they can do
things like unscrew the lid of a jar or
something and and get themselves out of
it and things like that but there are a
limited number of things like that that
they can do they just happen to have
some some I mean we call it reflexes
they might say it's their amazing
cultural sort of Heritage um that uh uh
that lets them take do those particular
motions
let's
see yeah I mean this whole question RBS
is commenting the future the Earth would
probably be a big brain if every
connected computer on the internet was
running neural computations yeah I mean
this the fact is
that you know this whole question about
the organization of of humans with cells
and neurons in our brains and that
builds up to a whole brain that has a
whole unified idea of what's going on
and then you build up to Human Society
does human society have a unified idea
of what's going on I don't know as as
individuals in that Society you might
say no it doesn't but looked at from the
outside you might say well you know
Society is deciding to go in this
direction just like in a sense if you
could query our individual neurons in
our brains they wouldn't have a coherent
idea probably of what's going on that's
something that builds up in the
collective so to
speak let's see
uh sapo is asking what what if we need
to deal with Concepts that need more
neural mass than we possess you know I
think this is one of the interesting
things about well knowledge education
and so on you know as a species we're
learning more stuff and yes the amount
of time people go to school has
increased although the dynamic of why
that's happened I don't think it's
because there's more stuff to learn in
the world I think it's because of the
the sort of the bigger institutional
structure of of schooling and and its
level of efficiency and this that and
the other but you know the question is
why is there just not you know why don't
we have to go to school for 200 years to
learn to be functional in the world
given how much is known and and the
answer I think is that at any given
stage there are both new things that get
known and new abstractions that get
formed new equivalences that get
discovered like we don't have to know oh
back in the day we might have had to
know in detail all the different kinds
of computers that exist because well
they all work differently and they all
have this and that and the other and you
know back in the day where where the
very early days of even electronic
computers it's like well it has a this
kind of word and that kind of operation
and etc etc etc but then and maybe this
isn't the best example but it's a
practical example that comes to mind uh
then pretty soon we just have to look
computers work this way it's just a
general abstracted thing that we can
think of computation as an abstract
concept and the same is true oh in in
lots of areas I mean you could say this
is uh
my well what's another good example I
mean
a
uh we might have to learn the
particulars of some thing about
mathematical knots for example and oh
you learn every particular knot and it's
this kind of knot and it's that kind of
knot maybe not even mathematical knots
maybe nautical knots as well knots as in
knotted pieces of rope rather than knots
as in nautical miles per hour um
although those are obviously related in
some uh historical way but but
um the uh uh you know you might have to
learn oh there's the tril knot and
there's the figure8 knot and there's
this knot and it does this and it does
that and you learn them all separately
and then there's some mathematical
theory that just says oh given the not
polinomial this is true and then you
only have to learn that one thing and so
I think there's these two processes
there's more facts that get learned and
there's more abstraction that happens
that sort of collects together facts
into higher level
Concepts and I think that somehow
there's a question question of maybe
there are high level Concepts that we
really don't understand very well that
our brains are just not very well set up
to understand it seems like what once we
kind of get familiar with higher level
Concepts we can deal with Concepts at
progressively higher levels we don't
seem to have trouble with that maybe um
I mean I think that uh um actually I
suppose in in some meta sense these live
streams of my attempt to take what are
sometimes quite complicated Concepts and
I hope try to explain them without a big
tower of kind of intermediate knowledge
so to speak and so you know in so far as
that works we're kind of learning that
there aren't kind of intrinsically
higher Concepts so to
speak
uh let's
see let me see I'm going to go to some
other questions
here oh there was one from Steven here
what do you think of the plans to shoot
feature films in space okay we're going
very different topic here uh I don't
know about those plans I I think it's
uh you know there have been a limited
number of movies that have been made on
planes in parabolic Flight you know in
in uh if you're in free fall then it's
well well when you're in orbit around
the Earth you are essentially in free
fall you're always Falling Towards the
earth except that because you also have
a a velocity going uh parallel to the
surface of the Earth by the time you've
Fallen to the by the time gravity has
made you fall to that point you're round
the other side of the earth so you just
keep going around an orbit but you are
as if you're just continually falling
and in that state you don't
feel the force of gravity so you know so
you you seem weightless and one can
simulate that by having a plane that
flies in a parabolic trajectory the
trajectory that something would fall in
if it was just falling so to speak and
um uh that's I've never taken one of
these flights I I get motion sick it
would be a disaster for me but um I
suppose when I times when I've flown
little planes I I've occasionally long
ago you know when you kind of you can be
in at least reduced gravity situation
fairly easily um but in any case the the
uh the sort of if you fly a sufficiently
close to parabolic trajectory you can
simulate Zog gravity and there have been
plenty of movies that have had scenes at
least that have been shot in kind of
those brief moments of zero gravity that
you get by going from 50,000 40,000 ft
or something down to uh to close to sea
level in a parabolic trajectory
um I think you know doing that on a
larger scale is surely doable um you
know there are lots of fun funky
phenomena in in microgravity or in zero
gravity uh that were very unfamiliar to
us like like for example um if you have
uh liquid you know for us on earth
liquid you're drinking something out of
a cup and the liquid is sitting in the
cup because it's pulled there by the
force of of gravity if you're in uh zero
gravity you move the cup and the fluid
will slide out of the cup and you'll
have a Big Blob of fluid just sitting in
the air and I know that that it's been
um astronauts don't like having big
blobs of fluid because that fluid gets
all over the place and you eventually
find little drops of of water just
hanging out in the space station in all
sorts of different places and you have
to vacuum them up and it's kind of a a
big nuisance but
uh you know that's an example of
something very nonfamiliar to us and
like there's a question you know what is
a splash like in microgravity I've been
been wondering about this I've asked
lots of people and a few experiments
have been done people are not very keen
to do the experiment because you tend to
you get this blob of water and you
shatter it into all these pieces and
then all those little blobs go all over
the place and it's you know it's it's uh
a nuisance so but that's an example of a
phenomenon that that see one of the
things that's that's funny you know you
see a movie and it shows a piece of
physics that is not part of our everyday
experience and you look at it and
sometimes you say that can't be right
for example this happened in the movie
Interstellar that had a very lovely
simulation I think it was actually done
with our technology um that of of a
black hole and um of oh gosh cre discs
maybe around a black hole things like
this and the the original version of the
movie the black hole was a spinning
black hole I think and it was had
everything sort of correctly sort of
represented in the ways that light rays
operate in in a in a curved SpaceTime
like that and it looked really weird and
for example the black hole wasn't a
circular thing it was a incredibly
flattened thing and people just sort of
said the test viewers or whatever sort
of said what the heck is that you know
that doesn't look like a black hole that
looks like some kind of weird black
pancake of some kind that we don't know
what it is and so the movie was kind of
Def physics so to speak to show the
black hole of something which it
wouldn't be actually what it would look
like so one of the things that I think
will happen if people start shooting
movies in microgravity is there'll be
all kinds of phenomena like that that
are extremely unfamiliar to us as
standard gravity dwellers so to speak
and I don't know how well we'll parse
those things and I suppose after a time
one will get used to it and say oh
that's a that'd be kind of interesting
you know that's a thing that was shot in
microgravity that's how things work in
microgravity you kind of extend your
experience now to also Encompass things
that happen in microgravity but I would
be sort of I I I'd be a little bit
suspicious that that at least at the
first instance it's kind of like very
alien I mean it's the same thing if you
look at things under a microscope for
example there are endless books of uh
you know what is this weird thing what
does it look like it's got all these
circles in it oh it's a piece of soap
under a microscope and so on they're
very unfamiliar to us and sort of a
question of what is it like to be
exposed to a movie or a video game or
something like this that is in a world
very different from our world I don't
know I mean I've been curious with our
ruad concept of sort of the space
possible computations and so on I'm not
a video game player myself but but uh
sort of what it's what it would be like
to exist in a different part of the ruad
so to speak from the one that we are uh
that we sort of sample normally uh
perhaps um and sort of what or even if
you think about sort of different laws
of physics what's it like to have very
different laws of physics in your video
game very simple example of this uh
going at speeds close to the speed of
light let's say you've got a video game
and I think people have made at least
some versions of this uh we've played
around with um some pieces of of things
of this type of um looking at uh sort of
what's the world like if your car goes
at 90% of the speed of light well it's
very different it has a lot of weird
features you know you're looking at that
Cube that's in front of you and oh well
it's actually Twisted because light
comes to the side of it that you're
closer to more quickly than it comes
from the other side and so the thing
will look Twisted it'll look kind of red
on one side blue on the other even
though it was it was neutral white color
uh sort of when you're looking at it at
rest and so on it's very unfamiliar it's
very I mean I you know I think it's been
sort of interesting to me uh you know
can one build an intuition for what life
is like at relativistic speeds and uh
back in the day when I used to be
involved in doing uh sort of practical
particle physics this is late 1970s
incredibly ancient past um I used to
visit particle physics experiments and
you would see these these big detectors
and things and you would know that
because of relativistic effects all
these various angles of oh this goes
from there to there at this angle the
angles that you intuitively think of
aren't the real angles that are relevant
because the angles that are relevant are
ones corrected for relativistic effects
for things going close to speed of light
but it's very unfamiliar to one and so
I'm I I wonder to what extent we'll just
look at sort of the true microgravity
thing and say wait a minute that just
doesn't look right and you know there's
a certain sense in which I don't know
you know explosions in movies I don't
know how accurate they are um there are
lots of issues you know if you make a
model for example either a physical
model as people used to do or a a
computational model model sometimes even
using some algorithms that I made up
long ago for somewhat different purposes
um with salometer and so on to simulate
you know explosions and fire and things
like this I actually don't know whether
when you um whether the real thing looks
like the thing you expect in movies um
and uh you know there has eventually
there is sort of a language that we
learn that is you know movie physics
that may or may not be the same as real
physics so I you know it will be
interesting if there's a very different
kind of real physics that one's exposed
to in movies I wonder what that will be
like um and I wonder to what extent you
know my guess is that it's a little bit
like well that if you if you throw
people too many unfamiliar things they
just get confused if you say oh we've
got uh you know a movie where there's
one or two really funky things that
happen because of the physics being
different then people will be like oh
that's cool but if it's too many it's
just disorienting would be my guess but
sort of the the the test case experiment
is the video game that operates
according to physics that isn't our
physics you know can you make one thing
we learned from sort of the story of the
rouard and so on we can make other
consistent physics is at least for
observers different from us now that
then raises the question when you're
doing the video game you know you are a
human Observer sitting in front of a
screen that is you know producing light
and so on how do you make an observer
not like us and that's sort of a
separate
question let's
see
uh okay there's a question here from
robot welln named what impact will
internet of things and 5G technology
have on our daily lives from Smart
cities to autonomous
vehicles so you know internet of things
having sensors everywhere maybe having
some actuators in different places is
something which multiple times people
have said it's going to change
everything so far it hasn't now that
isn't to say there are many things that
you see in technology in the development
of Technology where it's like it's going
to happen it's going to happen and it
doesn't happen and then eventually it
happens and it does change things often
unexpected things good example is video
phones the first demo video phones
existed in the
1950s but yet we didn't get routine
video sort of video conferencing until
what I mean I was using it from the
early 90s
occasionally uh
but um my gosh when did that come in as
a general thing maybe by maybe 10 years
ago or something it started to become
routine um and so that's a uh you know
that's a solid 50-year span relative to
when it when it you know was originally
sort of started to show up and there are
other things where sort of they show up
in imagined in science fiction 50 years
or more before they actually show up and
there are things so you know things like
everything there's a sensor in
everything is one of those things that
sort of the inexorable future but it
hasn't quite arrived yet I mean I I've
often thought that one of the things
that people say about sort of what's the
future going to be like and how's it
different from what we have today is uh
that you know right now we just say
there are computers in various specific
places but one can imagine imagine a
future in which everything is made of
computers every kind of piece of
material is made of molecules that we
can think of as doing controlled
computation hasn't happened yet but it's
something that presumably will happen
and once it's happened people will be
like what do you mean there was a time
when you would just have a thing that
was a fixed color of course everything
is programmable and can have whatever
imagery it wants on it you know that
that's a um uh that's kind of a a thing
which one can expect for the future but
but I think in terms of of sort of
sensor
technology um it's an interesting
question what okay what are some things
certainly in biomedicine there's a lot
of stuff like you know right
now most of the senses that we have are
in our brains and it's like oh you know
something hurts okay there must be
something wrong with you know that's the
error condition so to speak but there
will surely come a time when we don't
have to rely on our brains to know that
there's some issue with you know some
organ in our body or some something
that's going on we we'll you know it'll
be rather than uh it's like you don't
need to know that you feel hungry
because you have a signal in your brain
or you don't know you don't need to know
you didn't have enough vitamin B12 or
something which we don't know right now
maybe we get some vague cravings for
things but we haven't had enough of such
and such a kind of thing to eat but you
know one can imagine a time when that's
just a thing where look I've got this
readout it just says you know it's
measuring the blood level of of vitamin
B12 at all times and look I can see it
dip down and so on and so on and so on
and I think there is a certain amount of
sort of
self-awareness that we can imagine from
sort of uh sort of a sensors in us so to
speak and then there's a certain amount
of situational awareness for the world
from having sort of more sensors out
there in the world and obviously in you
know there's a transition like you know
webcams are a thing I don't know how
critically societally pivotal they are
and well depends what country you're in
and how they're used but but um uh you
know the the fact that we can have much
deeper sensing of what's going on in the
world uh you know has some some some
effects I think that the um uh for
example the fact that we can readily
have digital memory of the
past I've been one of these people who
collects you know endless sort of
personal analytics data and I have both
well my Digital Data going back into the
1980s and uh I've I've scanned my paper
data going back further than that um but
uh you know that makes I would say some
difference in you know the past is no
longer forgotten in the way that it was
before it's an outsourced kind of human
memory but I mean the the question of of
what
are you know as we get sort of more
sensors in our environment what does
that mean as we get uh I'm not sure I
know the answer to that I I think in
um uh I'm trying to think what kinds of
things would
be I mean what's always interesting is
when the cost of a
technology goes sufficiently low stuff
starts being done with it that you never
imagined like with computers you know
before the cost of computers was low
nobody could imagine doing word
processing or using computers just
purely for communications I mean it's
like you've got a computer it can
compute all this stuff and it's spending
all this effort you know running all
these things and then what's it doing
it's sending back and forth text
messages that's using a trivial
collection of the processing power of
the computer where it so happens that
video transmission uses a bit more
because of the way it's compressed and
decompressed and so on but in a sense
it's using a very shallow aspect not
quite so shallow because the compression
is fancy but conceptually it's a shallow
aspect of of computation and it it's
something where sort of as Things become
cheap enough you get to uh sort of do
them so so for example you know little
tags that you put in with uh you know
Bluetooth tags or whatever that say oh I
left my backpack behind or whatever else
you know probably there comes a time
when everything just has that in it as a
as a an you know everything you buy just
already has one of those things in it
and when you buy it uh you know it kind
of gets linked to your uh kind of
digital ecosystem and it's like okay so
then you can always tell where it is for
example it's not worth doing unless the
cost of those things goes down to the
point where it's trivial to sort of
print that into every object and I
suppose uh um you know what's another
example I mean there are all kinds of
things where you could imagine oh I
don't know with with food or something
you could imagine something where where
I don't know eat your sens you know eat
your Bluetooth device seems a little bit
un unappetizing but you can imagine a
situation where
uh I'm not sure if this is a good idea
but where you know all food has
something sort of mixed into it that's
really really tiny that you are able to
as you eat it it records a bunch of oh
you ate this number of calories of this
thing um because it it has that uh you
know just like it has a um I'm not sure
this doesn't sound very appetizing does
it it's kind of like um uh you know you
can think about the edible I've always
wondered what point genetic
engineering uh people talk about
genetically modified crops and so on
I've always wondered at what point
genetic engineering will get to the
point where you can grow barcodes or QR
codes or something on fruit and where
you know you go into the grocery store
and every you know every Apple has is
not just this green exterior but it's
something where because of its genetics
it has this barcode that uh describes
what type of apple it is or something
like that uh apples I think are all
clones of each other of a given of a
given variety are all kind of
genetically identical but one could
imagine something where where that's not
the case where it has kind of an
exposure of this is the uh uh you know
this is the particular Sub Sub Sub sub
variety that this particular thing is
but you know and that that one can
imagine again it feels a bit
unappetizing uh right now to you know
eat your Bluetooth uh transmitter but um
you know that's the type of thing where
if it's cheap enough and easy enough you
start to wonder about those types of
things and I suppose um uh oh for
example people wonder about coins and
Bank notes and so on and you know is
Cash going to survive forever and you
know cash is nice and simple and
Anonymous and so on um well of course it
might be the case that the idea of a
digital currency where which has sort of
features of trackability for better
worse um is uh uh sort of merges Because
by the time iot is cheap enough it's
like there's a there's a sensor in every
coin and um at that point it's kind of
like what's the digital coin versus
what's the physical here I can just pay
you this this uh quarter or something uh
you know how does that relate
um I think uh sort of a different
issue is 5G and telecommunication kinds
of things and at what point sort of what
has to be local versus what doesn't have
to be local and you know there's been
this kind of in the history of computer
technology there's been this kind of
back and forth thing is it local is it a
personal computer is it a Mainframe is
it the cloud you know I kind of find it
amusing as I think everybody who's been
in the business for a while does that
you know first there were mainframe
computers that were centralized then
there were personal computers then we're
back to the cloud which is essentially a
Mainframe computer where there are sort
of thinner local clients for it just a
web browser or something um and so
there's this continual back and forth
between the centralized and the
non-centralized and so the Dynamics of
that includes things like what's the
cost of doing a centralized Thing versus
a non-centralized Thing versus what's
the te telecommunications cost I think
one thing for example in the world of
llms right now we're in a very
centralized State you know you need lots
of Jeep CPUs and they're expensive and
they need complicated ecosystem around
them to to run the thing so so it's
worth centralizing those llms there will
come a time I'm sure when those will
decentralize um and uh it's the same and
I think there are things we couldn't do
right now with centralized llms because
the rate of getting data into them from
sort of our Edge our peripheral devices
is is too low now probably as one
imagines you know higher transmission
rates and so on um that becomes uh kind
of
less less significant I mean there's
sort of this question of when can you
transmit real-time video from sort of
anywhere to anywhere and how does that
work with you know how does that that
work with 5G and is that is it easy to
transmit sort of locally and then it's
complicated to to get it further away
etc etc etc but I think uh I mean
actually I was just looking at one
statistic which I'm curious about which
is what is the relative cost of the
training that's done on an llm which is
sort of a centralized Thing versus the
inference the actually running of the
llm I think it's like 10 to the 25
floating Point operations are the amount
of of operations done to train uh sort
of the fanciest llms these days and at
least to back of the envelope estimate
says that the number of of of uh steps
done in all of the uses of that llm is
actually now smaller than the number of
computational steps done to train it I
think if I got the estimate right um
which is sort of a strange situation
where you know the training is more
expensive than all the uses of it it's
kind of almost like like you could
almost say uh let's pre-process
everything we're going to do it's not
how actually works and you know bottle
up all that computational energy effort
and then let it out gradually so to
speak sort of an interesting not kind of
what I might have expected you might
have expected it's sort of online
real-time computation happening which it
is in actuality but sort of the
economics of it aren't quite like
that
so yeah I mean I think this whole
question about telecommunications speeds
and to what extent can we sort of rely
on Fast communication can we remotely
drive a car answer probably yes can we
you know to what extent do we uh you
okay so here here's a a question which
is human sensory data has a certain
bandwidth you know for audio data we
reach the 44 khz or something of of I
mean that's a that's an Overkill number
for
Human kind of audio bandwidth and we
reached that many years ago now as a
thing that we could just uh transmit
digitally for video we're not quite
there yet but we're not that far away of
being able to sort of remotely transmit
uh something which is as if you were
their um k type experience and one
assumes that you know there's a definite
point at which you can transmit as if
you were their experience for human
experiences so to speak we talked before
about sort of the super intelligent
whatever you know you scale up the
amount of sensory experience then you
stop being able to transmit all of it
but you know that that will be an
interesting threshold when we really can
transmit the whole Human Experience so
to speak uh easily and efficiently and I
don't know what the uh um you know I
have to say there are things that again
it's always strange what catches on and
what does not I sort of thought that
remote tourism would catch on that is
you say uh you know I want want to visit
some place
and you know I want to visit some
obscure
dangerous you know jungle location
somewhere I'd be really curious what
what's it like in you know whatever
Place well maybe I can get somebody who
is you know an experienced jungle
Explorer to just go wear all that gear
and um just you know I'm sitting there
and and I'm just you know immersively
watching this and they're the one
walking through the jungle but it's as
if I'm there and I sort of thought that
that kind of thing would catch on more
than it has it really hasn't caught on
at all I mean I kind of thought in in in
the world of job categories I kind of
was expecting you know a remote tour
guide or something like that to be a job
category it isn't yet maybe it will be
maybe 5G and sort of iot like technology
will allow that to be possible and again
I don't really know uh you know what are
the bigger consequences of that I'm not
sure I know uh it certainly would be I
mean one of the things that of course
airplanes opened up was kind of much
broader tourism around the world you
know by the time you had to take a ship
and it was pretty expensive and it took
three weeks and so on you weren't going
to go to this cool but distant Place
whereas if it's just a plane flight away
and the like isn't too expensive you're
going to go there and so obviously
Global tourism has dramatically opened
up and one could imagine what the
consequence of global tourism well I
mean all sorts of things about people
knowing more about what's happening in
other parts of the world people you know
transmitting viruses faster people maybe
transmitting ideas faster I don't know
um all kinds of other consequences of of
sort of economic Equalization from
people spending money in places where
there wasn't money being spent before
versus people kind of uh uh sort of
turning into um you know having fast
food joints in places where it was very
natural before so to speak U you know
all kinds of different things but you
know something like uh routine remote
tourism would probably have other
consequences and I don't know what they
are
yet
uh actually gavan is commenting someone
should start a touris
live stream channel they should they
should why hasn't somebody done that
obvious thing to do um it's uh uh yeah
good idea somebody here should do that
it's um
uh okay Mark is asking do you think in
the future humans could interact with
AIS via visualization of latent space to
create new new
Concepts oh I've wondered about this so
I mean what happens in a in a typical AI
system is there's sort of the images
that come in as the images are usually
viewed on a computer just with pixels
and so on and then there's this grinding
up into arrays of numbers that happens
inside a neural net and that's a
compressed version of the image we don't
know quite what the compression is the
neuronet has leared that compression
maybe the compression is bit number 17
represents whether there's a blue spot
in the top leftand corner or something
um probably uh um the uh uh you know I
don't know um
um what uh
uh yeah I mean so so we don't know what
what kind of that that internal
representation that sort of compressed
internal representation how it
represents things but an interesting
possibility is that we could become
familiar with the sort of sensory
experience of latent space yes I had
been interested in this and I did some I
wrote some piece recently that uh well
at least I nicknamed the cats piece
because it's mostly about images of you
know it has lots of images of cats in it
generated by generative AI this question
of sort of getting a human wrapping our
brains around the latent space this
internal sort of concept space of the of
the AI I interesting thing I I I have to
say you know in my efforts playing
around for a few weeks uh with cats and
party hats and generative AIS and so on
I was able to get some intuition about
what was going on but I certainly don't
think I was a fluent sort of uh thinker
in latent space and it's interesting
question of whether you could get
there
um comment about my the remote tourism
comment uh Missing the ability to try
the food a major reason to actually go
somewhere um uh do you think there's a
way to taste via computation that was
the immediate thing that I wondered
about you know we
have
know back in the
day it wouldn't have been obvious to
anybody that you could put little
loudspeakers in your ears and hear a
sound from anywhere the fact that we can
emulate the production of sound that way
or or or for images even more so that
you could have you know people would say
well I can paint a painting and here it
is but the idea that you know 60 times a
second or 30 times a second you can be
changing every pixel there and changing
your visual scene wasn't a thing so it
makes one wonder you know we are not
used to okay so the the obvious question
is the human tongue has a bunch of taste
buds and taste receptors and so on on it
now the fact is that taste is quite
texture dependent there are sensors in
other parts of one's mouth things like
this but um
uh one um you know could you imagine a
situation in which there's kind of you
you are you just suck on this thing it's
like a lollipop or something but it's a
a a highly uh electronic lollipop and
that Lolli poop is uh effectively giving
sensory input to the taste buds your
tongue and through maybe some electrical
process or something like this and you
are effectively tasting The
Taste I don't know whether that's I mean
one of the things that one wonders about
is you know can one feel the the the
touch of something and that's the whole
story of haptics and there is a certain
amount of you can fool our touch sensors
by electrical means or you can actually
generate the texture uh by uh the sort
of mechanically generate
electromechanically generate the texture
and then you're feeling the fur or
something because it really is fur like
on that surface as opposed to just you
feel electrical signals that are like
the fur you know I tried a a horrifying
invention a couple weeks ago somebody
has of a a thing that gives pure
electrical signals that affect the
vestibular system the balance system of
the brain and uh you know you it on your
neck and it it's it's kind of sending
electrical signals um I have to say that
that for me it was 5 Seconds to motion
sickness so that was um but you know
maybe that's just the technology isn't
properly developed but this question of
you know can you can you fool your
sensory system somehow in the case of
well one could argue that whenever we
look at a computer display we're fooling
our sensory system because for example
the uh you know there are discrete
pixels there are just red green and blue
pixels it's not the arbitrary kind of
frequency spectrum of an actual object
that is a it's it's full color so to
speak it's rather just being fooled by
being excited in the the three sort of
um corresponding to the three types of
cone cells that we have in our in our
retinas so in a sense we're already
doing a certain amount of fooling and
the question would be can we so can we
fool The Taste system um and uh
uh that's um it's an amusing question
and can we fool the kind of haptic
texture sensing system as well I don't
know um and uh you know at what point
are we really doing something a bit
silly where we're sort of you know
hacking into the brain and it's kind of
like well it's as if you were there
because the higher levels in your brain
process things that were the things you
would have got if uh you know if you
were there your lower level brain bra
systems would have processed the raw
data but actually one's just plugging
into higher level brain systems and
feeling what one would feel what one's
lower level brain systems would have
felt if one was in that place so yes I I
don't know how that would work
um
uh Alexander says I mentioned on
Wednesday that I was working on a course
about computational thinking can I
comment on how that's going it's not
gone very far since Wednesday it's got
It's probably progressed by a few pages
since then uh I hope I'm going to really
get a chance to to dig into this in the
next um or probably by the beginning of
next month and I and and I still have to
figure out what I'm going to do as
I as I write more of this whether I'm
going to sort of release it in pieces or
whether the pieces are going to be too
too sort of
incoherent to to be able to put them out
so that's a it's a thing I've been
thinking about but the the main kind of
point there is kind of this is
computational thinking is kind of this
this way of thinking in organized
fashion about the world and I'm really
trying to explain sort of how one should
do that just like one could say well you
could have a an explanation of
mathematical thinking you have to know a
certain amount of mathematics to be able
to do mathematical thinking if you don't
know the math you can't apply it to
thinking about the world and so
similarly here I think there's a certain
amount that you have to sort of know
about what's involved in computation
before you can apply it to thinking
about the world and so that's what I'm
trying to uh trying to uh work
on all right let's
see I'm um probably need to go soon hold
on one
second
um oh the
um
uh
let's see maybe one more if I can find
them it's always dangerous when I say
let me find a question that um is
uh
um let
see
um
I think these
are
all long stories
uh H okay all right this is what maybe I
can try and address from my
Peak when is AI going to travel the
Galaxy on its own and create its own
habitat on a different
planet you know I think the thing to
realize is computation is happening
everywhere we have built computers that
do sort of follow rules and do things
that we sort of built them to do but
there are processes in nature that are
following rules and doing complicated
things we didn't make up those rules
those came from nature but they're still
computational processes now of course at
some level we didn't make up the rules
for the AIS they came from the whole
history of our Natural Evolution so to
speak they are the the inevitable
consequence of the natural process of
humans evolving and then doing their
thing and so on so this question of sort
of what's it like to do to say let's
send out our computational systems and
colonize the Galaxy so to speak well
computation already has colonized the
Galaxy it's sort of all of those
processes going on from nature are
already out there and I think that
there's even more than we know and the
things that we know we can tell or out
there are the particular slice of sort
of all of reality that we humans happen
to be sensitive to so I think this
question of of
um you know to what extent can we take
the things that we've created and in a
way where we recognize what's going on
have them go hang
out you know on the other side of the
Galaxy or whatever I think uh it's sort
of a funny thing because it's kind of
like the ultimate um
uh thing where you're saying it feels a
bit empty to just say I'm going to put
my signature somewhere and it's going to
be taken and it's going to be sitting on
on on Mars for example on some
spacecraft it's amusing but it doesn't
really you know what does it really do
for one and I kind of think that's the
same type of thing when we talk about
sort of AI formed in our image so to
speak going and hanging out in the in
the Galaxy it's kind of like we're
sending our signatures out there and
it's a bit of a so what it' be very
different if the things we were sending
out were utterly qualitatively different
from the things that are already there
but my my claim is the things that are
already there already these complicated
computations going on in the atmosphere
of some exoplanet or something like this
and so it doesn't really it's not like
we're seeding the Galaxy with something
vastly different the only thing we're
seeding it with are the particulars of
computations that we choose to do not
it's going from it's really dumb to it's
really smart and computational no it's
already smart and computational and
we're just sort of sending our signature
so to speak to these other places now
you know as a species there's sort of
this question of of how do we feel about
uh kind of sending our signature
everywhere and is that an important
thing for us you know I have a friend
who's been involved I think he has
another one going soon actually the the
sending objects to various places in the
solar system hitchhiking on various
spacecraft uh the objects hitchhike on
the spacecraft um and he's been kind
enough to send some some
things I've written in micro form so to
speak on on these uh on these
various uh
deposits is that really significant is
that really you know to have some sort
of
microscopic sort of version of Something
sort of a human produced thing sitting
on the moon or something like this does
it or further a field uh you know how
significant is that for us and is that
kind of the uh it's really very much a
personal SLS societal question is do we
feel that you know planting our flag so
to speak on Place XYZ is that really
important or is it like a shrug you know
I think uh I don't know how to think
about that I think it's it's um
uh I mean I suppose for me personally I
I'm not that I don't think it's that
exciting but you know maybe I'm just not
built as an Explorer of the right kind I
mean somehow I also can't help but
realize that you know we are let's say
roughly a meter in size the universe is
10 to the 26 meters across we are that's
a that's how big we are relative to the
universe if we think about what's the
universe made of in
our sort of physics project we have some
indication that the elementary Lang l in
the universe the shortest possible
length is maybe 10us 100 m so there's a
lot more room down than there is up
we're 10 the
26 26 orders of magnitude away from the
size of the whole universe yet 100
orders of magnitude above the size of
the elementary length so in a sense
there sort of more more stuff to go deal
with sort of right here sort of looking
at what's in on the small rather than
out there looking at what's in the
lodge it's an easy wrap-up question
being asked which is not easy for me um
have I ever had figgy
pudding I have no idea what that is so
the answer is to my knowledge no but uh
you know maybe that's one of the
deficits
I have from not having grown up in the
US uh I'm not sure anyway we should
probably wrap up there uh thanks for
joining me happy holidays and uh I think
I might be able to do one of these next
week perhaps um late in the week
otherwise I will
um uh be um doing this
again probably in the new
year so happy holidays thanks for
joining me bye for
now